[Music]
the fundamental root of a tall building
block for linear algebra is the vector
so it's worth making sure that we're all
on the same page about what exactly a
vector is you see broadly speaking there
are three distinct but related ideas
about vectors which I'll call the
physics student perspective the computer
science student perspective and the
mathematicians perspective the physics
student perspective is that vectors are
arrows pointing in space what defines a
given vector is its length and the
direction it's pointing but as long as
those two facts are the same you can
move it all around and it's still the
same vector vectors that live in the
flat plane are two-dimensional and those
sitting in broader space that you and I
live in are three-dimensional
the computer science perspective is that
vectors are ordered lists of numbers for
example let's say you were doing some
analytics about house prices and the
only features you cared about were
square footage and price you might model
each house with a pair of numbers the
first indicating square footage and the
second indicating price notice the order
matters here
in the lingo you'd be modeling houses as
two-dimensional vectors where in this
context vector is pretty much just a
fancy word for lists and what makes it
two-dimensional is the fact that the
length of that list is 2
the mathematician on the other hand
seeks to generalize both these views
basically saying that a vector can be
anything where there's a sensible notion
of adding two vectors and multiplying a
vector by a number operations that I'll
talk about later on in this video the
details of this view are rather abstract
and I actually think it's healthy to
ignore it until the last video of this
series favoring a more concrete setting
in the interim but the reason I bring it
up here is that it hints at the fact
that the ideas of vector addition and
multiplication by numbers will play an
important role throughout linear algebra
but before I talk about those operations
let's just settle in on a specific
thought to have in mind when I say the
word vector given the geometric focus
that I'm shooting for here whenever I
introduce a new topic involving vectors
I want you to first think about an arrow
and specifically think about that arrow
inside a coordinate system like the XY
plane with its tail sitting at the
origin this is a little bit different
from the physics student perspective
where vectors can freely sit anywhere
they want in space in linear algebra
it's almost always the case that your
vector will be rooted at the origin then
once you understand a new concept in the
context of arrows in space will
translate it over to the list of numbers
point of view which we can do by
considering the coordinates of the
vector now while I'm sure that many of
you are already familiar with this
coordinate system it's worth walking
through explicitly since this is where
all of the important back-and-forth
happens between the two perspectives of
linear algebra focusing our attention on
two dimensions for the moment you have a
horizontal line called the x axis and a
vertical line called the y axis the
place where they intersect is called the
origin which you should think of as the
center of space and the root of all
vectors after choosing an arbitrary
length to represent one you make tick
marks on each axis to represent this
distance when I want to convey the idea
of 2d space as a whole which you'll see
comes up a lot in these videos I'll
extend these tick marks to make
gridlines but right now they'll actually
get a little bit in the way the
coordinates of a vector is a pair of
numbers that basically gives
instructions for how to get from the
tail of that vector at the origin to its
tip the first number tells you how far
to walk along the x axis positive
numbers indicating rightward motion
negative numbers indicating leftward
motion and the second number
tells you how far to walk parallel to
the y-axis
after that positive numbers indicating
upward motion and negative numbers
indicating downward motion to
distinguish vectors from points the
convention is to write this pair of
numbers vertically with square brackets
around them
every pair of numbers gives you one and
only one vector and every vector is
associated with one and only one pair of
numbers what about in three dimensions
well you add a third axis called the z
axis which is perpendicular to both the
x and y axes and in this case each
vector is associated with an ordered
triplet of numbers the first tells you
how far to move along the x axis the
second tells you how far to move
parallel to the y axis and the third one
tells you how far to then move parallel
to this new z axis every triplet of
numbers gives you one unique vector in
space and every vector in space gives
you exactly one triplet of numbers all
right so back to vector addition and
multiplication by numbers after all
every topic in linear algebra is going
to center around these two operations
luckily each one's pretty
straightforward to define let's say we
have two vectors one pointing up and a
little to the right and the other one
pointing right and down a bit to add
these two vectors move the second one so
that its tail sits at the tip of the
first one then if you draw a new vector
from the tail of the first one to where
the tip of the second one now sits that
new vector is there some
this definition of addition by the way
is pretty much the only time in linear
algebra where we let vectors stray away
from the origin now why is this a
reasonable thing to do why this
definition of addition and not some
other one
well the way I like to think about it is
that each vector represents a certain
movement a step with a certain distance
and direction in space if you take a
step along the first vector then take a
step in the direction and distance
described by the second vector the
overall effect is just the same as if
you moved along the sum of those two
vectors to start with you could think
about this as an extension of how we
think about adding numbers on a number
line one way that we teach kids to think
about this say with two plus five is to
think of moving two steps to the right
followed by another five steps to the
right the overall effect is the same as
if you just took seven steps to the
right in fact let's see how vector
addition looks numerically the first
vector here has coordinates 1 2 and the
second one has coordinates 3 negative 1
when you take the vector sum using this
tip to tail method you can think of a
four-step path from the origin to the
tip of the second vector walk one to the
right then to up then three to the right
then one down
reorganizing these steps so that you
first do all of the rightward motion
then do all the vertical motion you can
read it as saying first move one plus
three to the right then move two minus
one up
so the new vector has coordinates one
plus three and two plus negative one in
general vector addition in this list of
numbers conception looks like matching
up their terms and adding each one
together
the other fundamental vector operation
is multiplication by a number now this
is best understood just by looking at a
few examples if you take the number two
and multiply it by a given vector
it means you stretch out that vector so
that it's two times as long as when you
started if you multiply that vector by
say one-third
it means you squish it down so that it's
one-third the original length
when you multiply it by a negative
number like negative 1.8 then the vector
first gets flipped around then stretched
out by that factor of 1.8 this process
of stretching or squishing or sometimes
reversing the direction of a vector is
called scaling and whenever you catch a
number like 2 or 1/3 or negative 1.8
acting like this scaling some vector you
call it a scalar in fact throughout
linear algebra one of the main things
that numbers do is scale vectors so it's
common to use the word scalar pretty
much interchangeably with the word
number numerically stretching out a
vector by a factor of say 2 corresponds
with multiplying each of its components
by that factor 2 so in the conception of
vectors as lists of numbers multiplying
a given vector by a scalar means
multiplying each one of those components
by that scalar
you'll see in the following videos what
I mean when I say that linear algebra
topics tend to revolve around these two
fundamental operations vector addition
and scalar multiplication and I'll talk
more in the last video about how and why
the mathematician thinks only about
these operations independent and
abstracted away from however you choose
to represent vectors in truth it doesn't
matter whether you think about vectors
is fundamentally being arrows in space
like I'm suggesting you do that happen
to have a nice numerical representation
or fundamentally as lists of numbers
that happen to have a nice geometric
interpretation the usefulness of linear
algebra has less to do with either one
of these views than it does with the
ability to translate back and forth
between them it gives the data analyst a
nice way to conceptualize many lists of
numbers in a visual way which can
seriously clarify patterns in data and
give a global view of what certain
operations do and on the flip side it
gives people like physicists and
computer graphics programmers a language
to describe space and the manipulation
of space using numbers that can be
crunched and run through a computer when
I do math II animations for example I
start by thinking about what's actually
going on in space and then get the
computer to represent things numerically
thereby figuring out where to place the
pixels on the screen and doing that
usually relies on a lot of linear
algebra understanding so there are your
vector basics and in the next video I'll
start getting into some pretty neat
concepts surrounding vectors like span
basis and linear dependence see you then
you